comment ça le mystère de black widow et
bien oui c'est le sujet d'aujourd'hui on
en a très peu parlé pourtant un film
dédié au personnage est prévu mais du
coup pourquoi ce film en fait genre
c'est quoi son utilité pourquoi il est
là car après tout natacha est morte dans
endgame en fait
eh bien le voilà le mystère que nous
allons tenter de résoudre
bien que peu hype ont pour beaucoup de
monde m'a le film de black widow et le
premier film officiel de la phase 4
et du coup il a son importance déjà
recontextualise on le film mademoiselle
romanoff alias black widow est une à 20h
et suite aux évènements de civil war le
groupe s'est scindé et chacun est parti
un petit peu de son côté que ce soit
tony steve rwanda banner vision etc
sauf que voilà natacha les avengers
c'est sa famille et elle se retrouve
maintenant seul au milieu de ces
tensions c'est pourquoi ces dernières
retournera vraisemblablement en russie
dans ses origines c'est là le premier
point de films de black widow situé
entre civil war et infinity ward a pour
utilité de rendre aux personnages un
hommage suite aux évènements de endgame
dans le mc ou natacha est un personnage
plutôt secondaires par rapport aux
autres avengers qui sont charismatiques
comme tony puissants comme thor ou de
véritables leaders comme steve bref
black widow et toujours dans l'ombre
comme un support le personnage possède
un rôle de soutien
mais il faut rendre à césar ce qui
appartient à césar
black widow est l'une des six avengers
d'origine est l'une des rares qui sur
les dix années de développement de la
saga dont nous ne connaissons quasiment
rien de son histoire
étant donné que les comics ne compte pas
tant que ça pour le mc hull néanmoins
est ce que cela vaut tant coup d'en
faire un film
est ce que c'est réellement pertinent
mais c'est ça le truc après tout ce que
marvel nous a proposé est accompli il
est impossible pour eux de nous proposer
un simple film d'action sur un
personnage
important mais bien moins hype et qu'un
tony un tort ou un steve par exemple la
grille d'eau est le premier film de la
phase 4 un film qui aura pour rôle de
transitionner endgame avec l'avenir tout
comme un petit peu spider man far from
home qui fut les pilotes de la phase iii
alors effectivement natascha n'a pas de
super pouvoirs il n'y aura pas de gants
d'infini ou de multivers etc
et c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
honorable endgame était une sorte de fin
pour marvel la fin de dix années de
films et suite à cette conclusion il
faut calmer le jeu et relancer la
machine soit scénaristiquement instaurer
une nouvelle ère de nouvelles mentalités
la reconstruction du monde et j'en passe
néanmoins je vous connais vous allez me
dire oui d'accord mais le film de black
widow comme tu l'as dit se passe dans le
passé donc nous ne verrons pas de
reconstruction etc
c'est très bien vu je vous félicite par
le biais du passé le film va pouvoir
mettre en lumière des zones d'ombré des
éléments inachevés ou encore mis de côté
et qu'ils auront de l'importance pour
l'avenir n'oubliez jamais que tout est
calculé chez marvel et tout est prévu
dans les films la période entre civil
war et infinity ward est très flou on
sait très peu de choses sur cette
période
alors bien évidemment il ya eu le film
de thor anja rock mais nous étions bien
loin de la terre dans ce film pourtant
il s'est passé plusieurs années dans
cette période et marvel décide donc de
mettre en lumière est justifiée ceci par
le biais de ce film d'ailleurs ce que je
peux vous assurez également c'est que la
période de l'ellipse comme il est dit
dans spider man far from home soit les
cinq années où les gens ont disparu puis
sont réapparues bas ce sera développé
dans un film ou une série futur c'est
certain en fait dans son fonctionnement
et ses objectifs
marvel veut
créée la hype et la continuité d'où
l'importance énorme des scène post
générique il y a et il y aura toujours
du mystère des suites
j'aimerais donc amené la thématique du
film de captain marvel ainsi que de
othman et la guêpe
ces deux films sont ce qui se rapproche
le plus de celui de black widow dans sa
conception effectivement si vous vous
souvenez bien le film de captain marvel
et de antoine et la guêpe sont sortis
entre le fiend infinity ward et endgame
pourtant ces films dans la temporalité
se passe loin dans le passé ou pendant
les événements d'in fi nit ivoire et
bien c'est ça le truc
le film de captain marvel nous présenter
carole ses pouvoirs et cetera son
histoire mais surtout servette a amené
une potentielle réponse ou problématique
quant à la résolution de la guerre
d'infini contre thanos c'est exactement
pareil pour antoine et la guêpe
ce film nous a permis de continuer et de
justifier ou était antoine pendant
infinity ward mais surtout étant donné
qu'il est sorti après infinity ward et
que tout le monde était concentré sur
endgame bas le film en plus de
développer l'histoire de scott langue
apporte des réponses et des solutions
quant à l'avenir du mc et donc la
résolution de nghe j'espère être clair
je ne sais pas si vous me suivez bien en
gros une fille d'ivoire est sorti puis
entre man et la guette avec le
développement du champ quantique et le
fait que scott se retrouve piégé dedans
et captain marvel nous a amené un
nouveau personnage qui en soi a eu un
rôle assez majeur entre guillemets dans
la guerre finale pour en revenir à black
widow c'est exactement la même chose le
film traite du passé mais amènera des
problématiques et des intrigues pour le
futur et je suis prêt à mettre ma main à
couper que la scène post générique du
film aura une importance capitale
bah oui qu'est ce que vous voulez teasé
à la fin du film black widow en rapport
avec natacha alors qu'on connaît déjà
une finity war il est presque sûr et
certain pour moi la fin du film et où la
scène post générique très sera du moment
de la mort de natasha sur vos remirent
avec potentiellement l'arrivée de steve
qui souhaitent rendre la pierre et serez
face à red skull
c'est quelque chose que l'on aimerait
tous voir imaginez si steve lors de son
retour avec les pierres arrive juste
avant le grand saut de natacha la mort
du personnage fut un événement qui a
beaucoup affecté steve étant ultra
proche de cette dernière comme captain
america natacha a passé sa vie à
combattre
que ce soit pour le shield ou d'autres
mais surtout elle a fait énormément
d'erreurs de choix entre guillemets bref
elle a perdu énormément
cela permettrait de lui donner une
seconde chance mais cela créerait un
conflit temporel mais bon ce serait loin
d'être le seul
1 une continuité pour le personnage de
taskmaster pourrait être à prévoir
également puisque ce dernier de
souvenirs dans les comics agi quelques
fois avec les avengers ou des ennemis
tant qu'il ya de l'argent en jeu
c'est un personnage plutôt importants de
l'univers il est possible que cela ne
soit pas sa seule apparition surtout vu
comment ils copient les méthodes de
combat 2 black panthère ou encore
captain america ce serait intéressant de
le voir potentiellement affronter
d'autres héros dans le futur mais bref
on s'éloigne un peu
enfin la possibilité de la reprise du
rôle de black widow par yale et n'a par
exemple serait possible il est clair que
la question de la famille de natacha
fait réfléchir il est clair que natacha
retournera avec steve puisque dans
infinity ward elle apparaît à ses côtés
lors de leur retour mais cela veut dire
donc natacha abandonnera de nouveau son
ancienne famille peut-être aurait-elle
garder contact avec eux jusqu'à un game
seul le film nous le dira toute façon
mais bon il est clair que thunderbolt
ross est toujours dans les parages et
lui je peux vous assurer qu'il est loin
d'avoir fini de faire du grabuge
bref il est vrai que le film est peu
hype ans et sera plutôt simple comparée
aux dernières productions
cependant il ne faut jamais oublier que
marvel et comme dr strange avec la
pierre du temps ils savent et prévoit
tout donc nous aurons des surprises mais
je vous avoue que ma crainte est que
comme pour antoine le film se résume à
sa scène post générique pour apporter
des réponses
enfin voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura pu malheureusement comme vous
le savez au vu des circonstances
actuelles le film a été repoussée ce qui
est normal et du coup bas sa sortie est
prévue pour octobre
il me semblait vraiment pertinent d'en
parler car même si le film est vraiment
peu hype ans en vrai bah il est là donc
il a une importance en tout cas c'était
très sympa de vous parler de ce sujet
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu un
commentaire puis à vous abonner on se
retrouve dans de prochaines vidéos c'est
et argo rock et que le lionheart soit
avec vous
[Musique]